n'est pas froide a fait ça va bah il
s'effraie mais je vais j'ai prévu gémit
quand on élève ne s'habillait rapidement
oui absolument j'ai vu des gens très
déshabillée chez vous quand même des
fils en bas france de l'hôpital depuis
un
bon soir donc votre mère simone signoret
disparaissent
d'accord notre mère donc simone signoret
disparue si il y à il ya 20 ans
exactement le 30 septembre 1985 de
nombreux hommages sont sont prévues pour
célébrer cet anniversaire mais nous
avons choisi de vous demander à vous
d'être là ce soir catherine vous sa
fille qui lui ressemble étant
effectivement comme laurent vient de le
remarquer un peu de catherine deneuve
alors ce 30 septembre 1985 simone
signoret était dans sa propriété de
d'auteuil yves montand et est reparti
dans le sud de la france où il tournait
mal an des sources et vous vous êtes
seul au chevet de votre votre mère quand
elle meurt au petit jour
quelles ont été ses derniers mots
catherine elle a pas parlé
elle a poussé un grand soupir et puis
voilà elle est partie ouais alors
benjamin castaldi va de votre fils
arrive peu après il dit dans son livre
qui s'appelle maintenant il faudra tout
se dire que lorsqu'il arrive l'ambiance
est assez festive finalement il parle
d'une espèce de sortie de théâtre
c'est à dire que mon temps a toujours eu
un rapport à la mort un peu particulier
donc il était très irrévérencieux et je
dois dire que ce jour là j'espère que
tout le monde va comprendre ce que je
veux dire on a beaucoup ri donc on a
fait une réunion
avec monsieur chapillon le roi du
réveillant qui était à l'époque le pdg
des pfg j'ose dire et
monte a commencé à faire un numéro de
star en dix ans
non matin parce que moi là pour la tombe
il faut faire attention les moindres
être en gros caractères quand même quand
ça m'arrive est donc là quand ça va
générer voilà alors il a commencé à
faire des grosses grosses plaisanteries
là dessus on était un peu fatigué et
très malheureux et à bout de nerfs donc
on se marrait comme des bossus et on a
dû nous rappeler à l'ordre
alors là vous monter dans la chambre de
votre mère donc simone signoret c'est
toujours benjamin qui raconte et vous
prenez ces bijoux peu avant de mourir
maman m'avait dit tiens ma chérie tu
t'ouvres le placard là en bas alors j'y
suis allée puis elle me dit tu vois ma
petite touche ma petite rousse mocheté w
à prend là alors je les prises les
ouverte et effectivement il y avait
dedans c'est ses plus beaux bijoux
j'aimais ça veut dire quoi ça ne me dit
pas mais au moins ça c'est sûr que tu
leur as vous avez arrêté de votre mère
oui j'ai hérité de ma mère j'ai su que
sa voix sa forme dieu ouais pas sa
couleur de l'argent un peu quand même
oui bien sûr lorsque sa hache et monte
on l'a mal encaissée que ce soit vous
qui héritiers de votre mère non quelques
années encaissé en tout cas
donc le lendemain toute la presse rend
hommage à simone signoret françois
mitterrand le présent à un public dit de
casque d'or aux droits de l'homme cette
comédienne cet écrivain aura parlé
pendant 40 ans au coeur des français
c'est vrai que ça a été un événement
national oui c'est vrai c'est vrai je me
rappelle quand on est arrivé au vu du
père lachaise sur la place avant
d'arriver montant était ébloui 10 et 4
tous ces formidables regarde tout ce
monde mais c'était une réaction de cabot
et en même temps ils avaient tellement
première pour lui les critiques ont été
bonnes
tous les cas il n'y avait pas eu autant
de monde au père lachaise depuis
l'enterrement de jean paul sartre ce qui
est quand même colossal
alors voilà donc simone signoret était
né en 1921 à wiesbaden en allemagne
voilà où son père était officier dans
l'armée d'occupation française après la
première guerre mondiale ensuite lui il
est rentré à paris il s'installe à
neuilly il a travaillé dans une agence
de publicité lagence d'amour et
finalement elle a eu une enfance assez
assez bourgeoise à neuilly votre votre
maman mais signoret c'était un
pseudonyme son père s'appliquera minker
juifs d'origine polonaise mais il a
donné aucune éducation juive à sa fille
est ce que vous savez pourquoi mais
parce que on peut être juif et non
pratiquants et non religieux halal halal
le côté juif de la famille camin caire
c'est quelque chose de parfaitement
sentimentale europe centrale et ma mère
est restée très maïs à elle le
revendique m bah oui d'ailleurs à la fin
de sa vie elle signe son premier son
dernier roman qui s'appelle adieu
volodia quelle histoire de juifs pauvres
immigrés à paris entre les deux guerres
qui est devenu un best-seller est ce que
c'est une façon pour elle de revendiquer
ses origines finalement non je pense pas
alors voilà donc en septembre 1939 c'est
la guerre la famille reste en bretagne
où il était en vacances
mais ils sont dénoncés aux allemands par
des bretons mal intentionnés et le père
à ce moment là s'en va à londres
rejoindre la france libre elle elle
rentre à paris et pour nourrir sa
famille simone signoret à l'époque
encore simone kaminker travail dans un
journal collabos les nouveaux temps de
jean luchaire alors l'a jamais caché cet
épisode un nom elle l'a non seulement
elle n'a pas caché mais quand elle est
partie et l'or il ya de la hauteur de la
naïveté de ses 19 ans vous serez tous
fusillés ouais
vous et comme
alors en fait elle a quitté le journal
parce qu'elle avait rencontré en mars 41
cents son premier amoureux qui la
convainc donc de quitter ce journal et
qu'il l'amène au café de flore où elle
rencontre la bande de jacques prévert et
c'est là qu'elle décide vraiment de se
lancer dans le cinéma quoi
apparemment elle avait ça en tête depuis
tout petit mais sa maman on n'a jamais
dit à moi qu'elle avait toujours désiré
faire ce métier quand elle racontait
c'était un petit peu comme si
elle avait eu du bol mais je crois
qu'elle l'a cherché ce brin si elle
voulait faire ça mais elle voulait parce
que elle prend le pseudonyme de signes
auraient quitté le nom de sa mère et en
même temps c'était le nom d'un acteur
très célèbre à l'époque donc elle se
fait un peu passé pour sa nièce quand
même elle croyait pas qu'elle n'a joué
que ça je pense pas non n'a pas besoin
de ça un moment à l'arrivée quelque part
je vais pas sur ce genre de choses à la
jouer sur son physique sur son talent
sur son intelligence et sur son humour
mais n'a jamais joué sur des pseudos du
pseudo filiation pas le genre de la
maison alors en 1943 elle rencontre
votre père yves allégret alors il est
fou d'amour pour elle il avait bon vous
vous mettrez vous en 46 et entre temps
est devenu une vedette c'est ça les
trois ans plus tard elle tombe sur les
montants
coup de foudre et là ça fait boum
elle vous a raconté la rencontre avec
mon temps non mais elle la raconte dans
son bouquin montant l'a raconté dans le
sien c'est devenu un truc c'est un peu
je ne sais pas j'ai l'impression tout on
la connaît l'histoire c'était pas dans
le bouquin de benjamin
[Rires]
cette saga il faut garder les bouquins
de la famille oui j'ai passé comment la
rencontre alors en fait c'est grâce à
acro là qu'elle avait connu avant
puisque croit light est un copain de
prévert et tout ça est comme ça elle a
rencontré mon temps et je pense que ça a
été assez fulgurant et assez rapide
puisque très vite
elle a mon temps a dit qu'il était
fatigué parce qu'ils chantaient de
soirée qu'il avait besoin de se reposer
et elle lui a proposé de l'héberger dans
la maison qu'elle avait à saint paul de
vence et balades de ce moment là ils
sont plus quittés chez pas si l'on est
là beaucoup dormi mais en tout cas ils
se sont plus quittés et elle divorce de
hill valley gré de votre père donc ce
qui était assez rare à l'époque c'est à
dire qu'il faut savoir qu'ils sont
restés très peu marier parce que moi
quand je suis né je me suis appelé cama
caire parce que papa pouvais pas me
reconnaître parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
divorcer il papa maman qui avait quitté
un peu parfois
pas toujours très gentil avec les
certaines personnes m'a toujours dit que
papa a eu envie de l'épousé quand elle a
commencé à devenir une star
dimanche
alors quand votre mère divorce d'yves
allégret donc
quelle part avec yves montand vous
devenez quoi vous moi je ne viens pas
grand chose moi je moi je reste je reste
là on m'a posé c'est à dire
dans la maison familiale du 56e rue
vaneau à l'époque avec papa maman elle
est partie avec une valise des slips de
rechange et une brosse à dents c'est
tout mais pas sa fille alors voilà donc
montand et signoret se marie en 1951
saint paul de vence ensuite elle a
énormément de succès avec casque d'or
thérèse raquin donc sur le plan
professionnel se passe très bien
sur le plan privé elle a beaucoup de mal
à faire un enfant il n'y arrive pas
finalement ils n'auront jamais d'enfant
ensemble non elle a perdu deux enfants
elle a fait deux fausses couches
tardives elle était enceinte de six mois
et non et voilà et ça c'était triste
ouais c'est une blessure terrible pour
elle ne pas avoir pu avoir d'enfant avec
eux c'est une blessure pour lui aussi
c'est une nouvelle sur pour eux ils
avaient très envie alors moi je vous en
parle pas parce que ça m'aurait vraiment
plus d'avoir un
frère à la maison j'aurais fait un
bouquin de plus
voilà ensuite avec mon temps c'est
l'engagement politique ils deviennent
tous les deux des compagnons de route du
parti communiste comme on disait ils en
font pas partie mais enfin ils
soutiennent le pc il refuse d'écouter
toutes les critiques qu'ils entendent
sur l' urss s'est dit assez aveugle et
quand même ils ont commencé à trouver
des choses un peu bizarre quand d'abord
budapest ça ne doit pas fait 13 56 56
hélas montant avait déjà signé sa
tournée en union soviétique
et
il a beaucoup hésité voulaient plus y
aller et ils sont utilisés en fait ils
sont utilisés comme un instrument de
propagande acquis ma part par les
communistes mais oui mais c'est sans son
camp c'est quand ils ont vraiment
commencé à s'en rendre compte ils ont
aussi vraiment commencé à se détacher
tout ça enfin quand même à catherine ce
n'est qu'en 1983 non mais ce n'est qu'en
1983 que votre mère dira le samovar
s'est finie sur 83 ces six ans avant la
chute du mur de berlin c'est quand même
très tard
oui peut-être pour le dire d'une façon
officielle on va dire mais mais ça ça
s'est fait bien avant
alors là il ya une aventure
extraordinaire dans la vie de mon temps
et de votre mère c'est le jour où je
m'entends va tourner à milliardaires
voilà et il tombe sur marilyn monroe
elle cette époque votre mère a beaucoup
de succès puisqu'elle a un oscar à
hollywood avec les chemins de la haute
ville elle devient une star
internationale
les 80 sur marilyn monroe quand même
s'il a dit à benjamin castaldi qu'il
répète dans son bouquin elle avait des
beaux seins mais pour le reste c'était
pas terrible
tu veux dire quoi
c'était quoi la réaction de votre mère
quand elle a appris cette histoire est
que 1000 été très malheureuse
était d'autant plus malheureuse qu'elle
aimait beaucoup marilyn mais là il ya eu
le feu quand même parce que longtemps on
n'était pas quelqu'un de
particulièrement fut-elle c'est de
notoriété publique
mais
mais c'était
des coups de chaud pas des coups de
coeur et là vraiment il a les moyens me
l'a dit qu'il a vraiment failli pas
rentrer il était amoureux elle était en
plus de ça elle était
paraît-il j'ai déjà mes rencontres et
malheureusement mais il paraît qu'à la
ville elle n'avait rien de cette espèce
de poupées glamour c'était une enfant
est quelqu'un d'extrêmement fragile et
parfaitement séduisant et gentil et
voilà il m'a mensuel a été vantée et
elle a vu elle était là je veux dire
qu'elle a bien vu qu'il se passait
quelque chose n'était pas idiote n'y a
pas de femmes qui passent à côté de ce
genre de flash c'est pas possible
le problème c'est que votre mère
vieillissez plus vite que mon temps
d'une sortie face maman était très
orgueilleuse longtemps madame m'a
raconté que un jour il a trouvé maman en
train de sangloter devant son miroir
elle avait 30 ans et elle venait de se
découvrir sa première fille et c'est
quelqu'un qui a passé sa vie quand même
à dire qu'elle s'en foutait que la
chirurgie esthétique à dire est parce qu
elle a fait d'ailleurs n'y est pas allé
qu' il fallait laisser le temps faire
des choses et tout prendre sa place mais
là je pense que franchement elle après
le
le tgv au lieu de prendre le tortillard
montant a dit en parlant d'elle être
l'amant de casque d'or c'est facile mais
il faut beaucoup d'amour pour rester
avec madame rosa et c'est vrai que lui
ça parfaitement dégueulasse
personnellement qu'il ait dit ça oui
peut le penser il peut lui dire à elle
quand ils s'engueulaient mais on n'écrit
pas ça dans un livre ou le dit pas
il va y en avoir beaucoup d'amour parce
que malheureux comme il était à
disparition de maman même malgré tout ce
qu'il y avait autour
ils se sont tellement aimé de toute
façon que c'est vrai que lui en
vieillissant il devenait de plus en plus
beau c'est horrible oui c'est une façon
de voir les choses
tous les hommes deviennent plus beau me
sens beaucoup en tout cas tu toi
lui pas lui
alors elle se met à boire aussi quoi
elle prend vraiment cette tête quand on
lui connaît et elle fait une deuxième
carrière au cinéma ce qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est là qu'elle fait le
chat la veuve couderc la vie devant soi
où elle joue le rôle de
la un césar en 78 c'est à dire que ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'elle
arrive finalement à profiter de cette
nouvelle apparence pour cher comme on
dit maintenant voilà ouais c'est
vraiment oui elle gère hadjer comme on
dit maintenant partout mais non je pense
franchement avec le recul et avec ce que
j'ai su d'elle je crois que franchement
elle était très très mal et la relation
qu'elle a avec mon temps à l'époque il y
avait plus de relation physique
j'imagine c'était unique bravo moment
comme on dit à marseille oui ça a
commencé à se déglinguer je pense
justement à l'époque de marilyn ça parce
que c'est pas un truc qui vous met l'eau
à la bouche ces choses il donc lui en
fait ce qu'on sait maintenant c'est que
il monte en rencontres carole amiel bien
longtemps avant la mort de s'ignorer
vous la voyez vous à l'époque car la
mienne dans le dos de votre mère
oui écoutez je voudrais pas faire
de zèle cost mais si je commence à
parler de carla miel je vais dire des
grosses bêtises et je vais avoir des
gros ennuis donc j'aimerais mieux pas en
parler mais on peut dire juste pour
répondre à votre question parce que je
suis bien élevé que oui je la voyais oui
on se voyait avec maurice mon mari mon
temps parce que mon temps
à l'époque comme tout ça a été quand
même un petit peu secret et que maman
était vivante on est bien d'accord là
dessus
on ne servait un peu d'alibi conserver
un peu de wire de poissons anton aller
dans les restaurants ensemble à quatre
on est plus discret 4 2 quand ce que
l'on pouvait penser que carole amiel
était une amie de maurice ou de ou de
vous voilà bah oui vu son âge elle était
plus proche de nous ml est beaucoup plus
jeune que moi donc
ouais vous la voyez plus aujourd'hui
[Rires]
oui je me marre parce que vous savez
j'en ai tellement bavé l'année dernière
que j'ai pris le parti d'en rire je vais
très vulgaire mais j'essaye de tirer la
chasse comme l a fait un livre carole
non
belges pas l'impression l'impression
qu'on a c'est finalement plus personne
se voit dans cette famille un jour ils
écrivent beaucoup
non mais c'est vrai non bah oui c'est
comme ça la vie c'est pas rigolo mais
c'est comme ça qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire faut sauver sa peau aussi un
moment donné on se dit ça va pas je vais
pas mourir vous ça va ça va mieux
beaucoup mieux cet ensemble oui prépare
approché en boucle la
benjamin vous le voyez souvent benjamin
est très occupé il overbooké même comme
il dit bommer bouquet la culture voir sa
mère ma patronne rabat à
bajamont temps à battre
est ce qu est ce que le livre que vous
avez écrit ou vous racontiez ce qui
s'était passé avec yves montand que vous
étiez tout jeune est-ce que ce tout
jeune et puis ils ont quitté depuis
longtemps après oui est ce que ça vous a
libéré mais je jouis ça m'a libéré dans
un premier temps puisque moi j'ai écrit
ça pour pour arrêter les calomnies de
journaux pourtant réputé plus ou moins
sérieux qui ont quand même titré sur le
fait que je couchais avec mon temps
alors que non alors que combats non
j'aimerais couché avec mon temps je
pense que ça aurait arrangé beaucoup
cameroun l'île bouquin on voit comment
voulu résister même joie place dauphine
dans la roulotte il se jette sur vous et
vous le l'envoyer péter comme on dit
poliment mais c'est vrai que vous n'êtes
jamais vous avez voulu mais pourquoi
parce que par rapport à votre manière
pas du tout il me plaisait pas ah oui
vous lire oui oui oh c'est horrible
j'aime pas les vieux
je n'ai pas les vieux merde non mais
thierry voilà je n'ai pas peine plus
vieux très vieux connaît
depuis longtemps pour moi il était quand
même très vieux quoi il vise à draguer
pendant des années passées quand elle
contient le tournage du sauvage aux
bahamas
vous avez jamais cédé est-ce que vous
pensez que votre mère savait que mon
temps vous tourner autour des souris
bien sûr et elle pensait que c'était un
moyen pour le garder lui non c'est moi
qui pensais ça mais en même temps je
pense qu'il trouvait sa jolie quand je
dis ça je choque mais non elle aurait
trouvé ça beau parce que c'était un peu
la continuité de son histoire à elle je
sais pas si c'est un truc qui se passait
dans sa tête c'était pas si ils sont ma
fille c'est balèze ne tirera pas c'est
pas ça du tout moment d'abord n'était
pas vulgaire question de suggestions oui
c'est ça c'était une forme de dans sa
tête ça aurait pu être un
un passage de relais même mois pour moi
le plus hâtif putatif
merci d'avoir évoqué simone signoret
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu